twenty years after Princess Diana's
death a new documentary has revealed
part of Diana's life that she tried very
hard to keep private
that was her role as a mom Diana our
mother her life and legacy aired on HBO
last night and it shows there is still
some grieving to do especially by her
son sons that's Prince William and
Prince Harry of course Elizabeth
Palmer's outside Kensington Palace in
London Liz good morning good morning
Kensington Palace behind me is where
Princess Diana lived after her
separation from Prince Charles
it's where the heir to the throne Prince
William lives now and it's also the
location for some of the interviews in
that documentary the public Diana was a
shape-shifting celebrity a glamorous
princess who doubled as a humanitarian
activist and in private she was
something else too
she was on mum she still is on mum you
know of course as a son I would say this
she was also a mom with a sense of
mischief and some very famous friends
just outside this room where we are now
she organized when I came home from
school to have Cindy Crawford Christy
Turlington and I'ma camera waiting the
top of the stairs I was probably 12 or
13 year-old boy who had posters them on
his wall and I went bright red and
didn't quite not would say and sort of
fumbled and I think I pretty much fell
down the stairs and the way out
Nick Kent and Ashleigh getting produced
the documentary for the 20th anniversary
of Diana's death it's a very simple film
really it's a love letter from two boys
to their mum and I think if it's
anything it's a sort of film about love
and memory and that's those are the two
things that really come across things
most strongly in the film as Diana's
Fame grew so did the pressure from
relentless paparazzi as apparent
something William who fiercely protects
his own family's privacy is bitter about
to this day I don't believe he's been
chased by 30 guys on motorbikes who
block your path who spit at you who
shout at you and who react really badly
to get a reaction from you and make a
woman cry
in public to get the photographs I don't
believe that is appropriate Diana died
in Paris in a car being pursued by
paparazzi her son spoke briefly with her
that day on the phone from Scotland
where they were on vacation with their
dad Prince Charles not knowing that that
was the last time I was going to speak
to my mum and how differently that
conversation would have would have
panned out if I had even the slightest
inkling that that was her life was going
to be taken that night the Prince is
very unusually opened up to the
documentary crew for this the occasion
of the 20th anniversary of Diana's death
but they're saying at least at the
moment that they're never going to do it
again
Gale oh but I love lists thank you so
much that they're sharing what they're
sharing with us it's so nice to hear my
favorite Diane as she has on that red
and white check coat mm-hm and her sons
are running her and her arms are
outstretched that's the biggest hug but
Charlie you're the only boy at the table
can you imagine as you're 12 and 13 and
your mom makes arrangements for a Naomi
Campbell and Cindy Crawford to be
standing there to say hey that's kind of
nice right would love to have been there
yes that would be a nice gift thank you
mom love that now see what we can work
up Gail right we know people Nora
Elizabeth Palmer in London we thank you
again